what is going on everybody welcome to
sixth Monte Carlo in Python tutorial
video in this video we're going to kind
of expand on our double or better guy
and give ourselves a little bit of
statistics on the outcome of this better
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so down here what we're going to
want to do is add a few more variables
here so first we're just going to say X
x equals zero that's just going to be
our counter and then we're also gonna
have a broke count and that's going to
be zero to start but obviously
eventually get some more broke people so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to say Wow X X is less than let's
do a thousand so one of a thousand
examples we want to run double or better
and then X X plus equals one at the end
of that we'll go ahead and show the
other thing we want to do is we want to
update this broke count so well come all
the way up here and we're going to add
in a global variable here and that
global variable is going to be a broke
underscore count and then down here
every time we go broke we're just going
to add one two broke count so here we
went broke after X Betts broke count
plus equals one just copy that we come
down here wrote count plus equals one so
then once we've done that part the other
thing we wouldn't mind doing since we
have a thousand of these guys is we
don't need to be printing out everything
that happens otherwise we've got a long
way to go so just comment out all of the
printing we're doing here I've got a lot
of prints happening my print print print
print print got this print this print
I'll even get rid of value and then at
the very end we'll we'll leave that one
there that's not a problem
um then actually you know let's get rid
of this we can see it anyways
so we've got that going on now so the
next thing that we want to do see did we
add them okay we've got broke count so
now at the very end
like before plot show let's do a print
and we'll do death great and so this is
going to be like how many betters broke
so it's going to be broke underscore
count divided by flow X X and we have to
just save flow to X X so it'll give us
what we're looking for and then x 100 so
it's a percentage then we'll go ahead
and print a survival rate and survival
rate is of course basically the opposite
of this so 100 minus broke count divided
by float X x times 100 and we'll put
this in parentheses as well okay and
then just to show us our break line
we're going to do plot dot a X H line
and then where do we want that
horizontal line at zero and what color
do we want it to be red because it's
showing who failed and that should be it
so we've got a let's run a hundred just
first just to see if this is working so
that should be everything we need so
let's go ahead and run it and sure
enough here we go we've got our guys
here and it looks like I don't see
anybody that broke exclaiming people did
go broke though so here we go after a
thousand bets and a hundred betters the
death rate is apparently 78 percent in
their survival rate is 22% I think the
difference is we just were breaking
before we actually plot the loss so
probably a lot of these guys lost again
we'll fix this we'll fix this soon
anyway so we can see the guys who you
know survived was 22% but other than 22%
of people that serve
you can see that you actually did pretty
well so the at the end of the day you
have to kind of weigh the costs are the
risks versus rewards here because if you
succeeded with this strategy you're
you're doing probably okay you know you
actually made a good amount of return so
if you did this over and over you might
do a what okay now let's see if this
figure sticks and instead of only a
hundred betters let's do a thousand
betters and see if the death and
survival rate they should be relatively
similar so we can see survival rate
actually went up a little bit with the
more better so this is a more realistic
sampling anyway so we've got that and
let's do ten thousand for one more just
to see my guess is probably closer to
seventy five and twenty four but we had
a lot of failure initially oh my bad I
was editing the wrong number this is
wager count so obviously if they do a
lot enough wagers a lot of these guys
will die eventually because they're
carrying a lot of risk but with a
thousand wagers it's not that much risk
anyway let's do ten thousand betters
again hopefully it's gonna this should
be closer to seventy five and twenty
four though wait for it
maybe I'll pause it while we wait or
something
and actually we see here that the death
rate is more likely the original results
that we had about 78 and 22 anyway it
much larger sample size here but money
all these died died died died anyway but
with only let's say they only go through
a hundred wagers uh we'll just do a
thousand of these guys if they're only
doing a hundred wagers you can see now
that the survival rate is actually
pretty good with only a hundred wagers
and not only is it pretty good but as
long as you weren't one of these people
at the end you made pretty good money
you want maybe got almost a 50% return
for some of these guys now overall we
still want to find out it's not just did
you go broke the other question is of
course what we're discussing right now
did you actually make money so how many
people went broke and of the people that
didn't go broke how many of those people
made money so that's where we're going
to keep kind of digging into this and
see how good this kind of strategy
actually is and then again like I
mentioned we'll actually use the Monte
Carlo simulator to actually find us the
perfect multiple because really a
multiple of two might not be the best
maybe the best idea is a multiple of
three and the other question is what's
our wager sighs so the waiter size is
most likely going to correspond to be a
percentage of how much total wealth you
have but maybe the better starting wager
would be something like $30 and triple
every time you lose or $30 and multiply
by one point five every time you lose
you know you know you don't know until
you actually play it out and see what
the outcome is so that's what we're
going to end up using Monte Carlo for is
to actually find all of those numbers
and probably I'm guessing the most
significant number that we'll find is
what fraction of your starting pot
should you wager each time because
that's obviously directly correlated to
how much risk you're you're taking on so
anyways that's what you guys have to
look forward to in the future videos as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time